cette semaine notre coup de coeur et le
film joyeux bordel avec deliver aniston
à la tête de l'entreprise familiale
carole menace de fermer la branche
dirigé par son frère fêtards et son
équipe de bras cassés qui pense plus à
s'éclater qu'à faire des bénéfices
il n'en fallait pas plus à ce dernier
pour qu'il leur fixe une ultime mission
organisée dans les bureaux une soirée de
noël totalement épique et hors normes
afin d'impressionner un de leurs plus
gros clients convoité est signé un
contrat qui pourrait sauver leur boulot
oh pardon
noël tu vas t'éclater joyeux bordel
s'inscrit dans la ligne droite des
meilleures comédies du genre comme
projet x ou very bad trip des répliques
fusent
la réalisation est bien rythmé notamment
grâce à son casting jennifer aniston est
parfaite en patronne intraitable elle
incarne enfin le rôle d'une peau de
vache
quant aux autres comédiens ils sont eux
aussi impeccable de précisions le
spectateur à tout pour s'éclater et en
sortit racontant joyeux bordel est à
découvrir en cette rentrée 2010 est à
l'espace philippe noiret